we are we are going nuts backstage
many of us grew up watching jessie and
the cast members were growing up right
along with us
let's take a look back at some of our
favorite stars and find out what it was
really like behind the scenes
painless fills her backstage bff while
karen braar reveals which co-star he had
trouble communicating with
guys stop it stop it
guess what i'm headed for the big apple
some fans don't realize that actress
debbie ryan really
was jessie in more ways than one yeah
she played the role of jessie ryan
prescott but it was a part designed
specifically for her and from there the
show as we know it today was created
series creator pamela ells o'connell was
wowed by debbie's work on the suite life
on deck
and wanted to find a way to keep her on
the disney channel and showcase her
talents
jesse worked as a nanny for a
rambunctious family and in many ways
this mirrored what life was like for
debbie behind the scenes
like we work really hard but we play
really hard she was older than the stars
portraying the ross children but it
wasn't so long ago that she was a kid
herself
so she had a good idea of what they were
going through as they got used to their
new roles
when we started they had never been on
sitcom before
feeling like a nanny on set definitely
helped her get into character as jessie
and she said that the kids always had
tons of questions for her during filming
many child stars feel like they were
forced to grow up too fast but it's the
opposite for debbie ryan
she claims that sticking with disney
helped her hang on to her childhood
and that working on the suite life on
deck meant she knew what she was getting
into with jessie
but that doesn't mean there weren't any
downsides debbie was forced to deal with
this star describes herself as an
introvert and says it was a challenge to
be constantly surrounded by people for
long periods of time
even sitting through hair and makeup
could be a challenge but luckily debbie
says that her co-stars were
understanding of the fact that she
needed space
at times and didn't take it personally i
need a little bit of alone time because
i'm an introvert
it's a good thing debbie felt like part
of a family on set because she also
found it hard to relate to people
outside of jessie
she compared growing up in the spotlight
to living in a world of chaos and said
that it was hard for other people to
understand the downsides of fame she had
to deal with
just another reason to love hanging out
with her fellow jessie stars
debbie claims that learning everyone's
quirks and personalities helped her
become the youngest woman to ever direct
a show on the disney channel
action according to payton list
growing up as one of three siblings
helped her prepare for her role on
jessie
her fellow cast members felt like family
fast and before long she considered all
of them her brothers and sisters
although she admits to having a favorite
nina said that her favorite co-star was
sky
jackson and that the two of them spent a
lot of time together behind the scenes
there are quite a few similarities
between the real-life peyton and her
character
emma they both love fashion although
peyton admits
emma has a slightly preppier style while
she was working on the show peyton was
living in a small
narrow house in brooklyn so pretending
to live in a mansion with a butler was
a bit of a challenge but thanks to those
sweet disney paychecks payton was able
to afford a much swankier place as an
adult
i have this amazing chandelier from
which is original to the house which was
built in 1926.
she and her fellow stars spent a ton of
time together and one of their favorite
pastimes was doing impressions of each
other
apparently they were a little too good
and helped the stars realize just how
much they knew about each other and how
close they had become over the course of
filming
not only did they laugh together they
learned together too
ian says they had two teachers working
with them on set
in addition to their online learning
while payton loved helping pick out
pieces for emma's wardrobe she was also
grateful to the makeup team who helped
hide her breakouts
while being a part of the disney family
helped hide her complexion woes
it also added some pressure to young
peyton who felt like she had to live up
to a certain standard
she was warned against doing anything
remotely scandalous that would tarnish
her perfect and pristine disney
image many fans were crushed when peyton
took her leave of bunked but she wasn't
sad to go
although she has many happy memories of
her time with the disney channel she
felt as though she grew up too much to
take part in children's shows
but that doesn't mean she doesn't have
fond memories and lasting connections
with the friends she made along the way
even when they're far apart the force of
love keeps them together
for cameron boyce getting a part on
jessie was a dream come true
in fact he admitted to being totally
starstruck the first time he met debbie
ryan in person
and when she called to tell him he got
the role of luke he thought she was
pranking him
i'm just shocked i still can't believe
it i still don't know where i am
i see the light but little did he know
that the real pranks wouldn't happen
until he was on set
apparently debbie is a big time
prankster and got the rest of the cast
in on the fun
including gifting them marshmallow
blasters that they love to aim
at kevin chamberlain we're pranking
people we're pranking each other
when cameron arrived for her first day
on set debbie picked him up and gave him
a big hug and he knew he had found his
family
when talking about luke cameron often
described him as mischievous so with the
amount of pranks going on backstage it
sounds like this star could relate to
his on-screen counterpart
but cameron also had a serious side and
hoped that his role on jesse would bring
some diversity to the disney channel and
inspire others to pursue a career in
acting cameron always knew how to make
his friends laugh
and he also knew when they needed
someone to reach out when debbie's mom
was battling cancer in the third season
cameron noticed her fatigue from
accompanying her to chemo treatments
debbie claims that cameron seemed to
know when she needed some comfort
and was always there with a hug and a
maturity that seemed far beyond his
years
he was also a talented singer and dancer
and would entertain his co-stars during
their time on set
apparently he was every bit as talented
behind the scenes as he was in front of
the camera
dean described him as an old soul and
said he left a huge
impact on her life of course jesse
don't worry i'll make you proud
we've shared plenty of sweet stories
about the jesse cast but there was one
member of the team
karen braar did not appreciate sharing
screen time with
frank if you're struggling to think of
this frank you might know them better as
mrs kipling
a seven foot long asian monitor lizard
who karen
was terrified of at first apparently
frank didn't take direction well
and what he had in mind usually wasn't
what the cast was hoping for
but other than frank karen loved working
with the less reptilian cast members
yeah like season one it was like hey
guys what's up
you said they loved hanging out in the
ross's living room and on the playground
in the central park set when they
weren't working
like his co-star debbie ryan karen also
had a role created
specifically for him originally the
character we all know and love as ravi
was going to be javier an adopted son
from south africa
but after meeting karen the casting
director decided to make some major
changes to bring this talented star onto
the cast
but there was one hurdle his accent yes
karen actually had to work with a coach
in order to develop an
indian accent in order to portray ravi
properly
he was so good at faking it that many
fans refused to believe it was really
ravi when they met him in person
according to karen he did a lot of
growing up on the set of jessie
and matured during his time on the show
like cameron he's also passionate about
diversity in the entertainment industry
after jessie ended karin eventually went
on to voice prince beer on meera royal
detective on disney junior
getting used to spending time with his
co-stars was easy and a ton of fun
but there was one aspect of fame that
was hard for karin to adjust to
makeup apparently he wasn't used to
wearing a full face of foundation and
kept
constantly smudging it off on his shirt
and occasionally his co-stars when he
would hug them
like the rest of the cast members he
loved to pull pranks but admitted that
debbie and skye were the most
proficient pranksters on the set
while sky jackson adjusted to working on
jessie right away
she admits that sometimes it was hard
for her to re-watch older episodes
i look at it back i was like my acting
is terrible
skye you were a kid cut yourself some
slack skye is one of the stars who felt
as though they grew up over the course
of jessie
and she believes that everyone's acting
progressed by the time the show ended
in addition to giving her a way to hone
her acting skills
jesse also presented skye with the
opportunity to meet
justin bieber yes skye is a belieber or
at least she was when she met him at the
age of 10.
she loved spending time with her fellow
cast members especially her big sisters
debbie and payton
skye even related to her character zuri
claiming that they both
share similar amounts of sassiness when
she wasn't hanging out with the cast of
jessie skye says she spent a lot of time
with the people behind lab rats
since they shared a studio and the fact
that lab rats had a popcorn machine
and a slushie machine definitely didn't
hurt
well we love to steal their slushies
because they have a slushie machine and
a popcorn machine but there were some
negative aspects of the show that young
skye was unprepared for
she was bullied both at school and
online for her appearance
which had a devastating impact on her
eventually she learned to love herself
and stop
taking negativity to heart she also
struggled to get over the fact that
despite their similarities
fans couldn't seem to separate skye from
zuri for a long time she felt pressure
to confront her haters but eventually
she realized there's a reason social
media has a block button
skye says that she and her jessie
costars have had a lot of heart to
hearts but for some reason child stardom
wasn't a frequent
topic and it was something she was
mostly left to figure out on her own
what's your favorite scene from jessie
share your pick with us and your fellow
disney channel fans with us
in the comment section down below don't
forget to click on that subscribe button
and turn on your notifications to stay
connected with us here at the things
we'll see you again next time